all right Matt welcome back thank you
it's a pleasure to be back you're you're
an interesting interview last time I
figured I'd bring you back for a little
more of your
of your life story thank you tell me how
you first got involved in gangs and all
that
gangs for me was a
I always grew up around gangs in the San
Fernando Valley um I grew up like I said
before I think between the cities kind
of an East Valley kid between like
Mission Hills and Sun Valley all the
little cities in between of San Fernando
Pacoima Arleta North Hollywood Granada
Hills adjacent um I was into graffiti I
was really into graffiti I love graffiti
as a kid and I was from a tagging crew
that throughout the 90s these Kagan
Crews mine included were interracially
mixed and at the same time we were
really violent we did graffiti but we
all acted like gang members only we
weren't gang members and as the
progression grew through the 90s a lot
of political things were coming down
through the jail systems to the streets
that these tagging Crews had to
had to if they're going to act like
gangs need to be a part of gangs and
then uh they need to get with the
program and they they dropped this I
don't like to speak too much like I said
about the jail politics but there was a
something came out through the jail
system so the streets were hey Ted Cruz
green light you join gangs or you're
going to be attacked from all angles
from all the gangs and so my friends had
committed uh one of my friends Brian AKA
lonely one of my best friends he uh him
and my other friend uh Mikey uh they
committed an act they killed somebody
and it was a brutal murder
um they uh which kind of forced our hand
into having to go forward with the whole
join a gang thing
and my father just so happened to own a
house and be working in the city of Sun
Valley at the big Crown Disposal dump so
I was fortunate enough to be friends
with some of the local tigers and gang
members over there and we slowly
transitioned into a gang in Sun Valley
and you think this lifestyle
kept you from doing anything else you
would have been talented at or had any
potential I agree I I totally agree with
that statement I uh I do feel that
graffiti was my calling and I so many
nights I think about this and I feel
like it just
I want to say that I love my homeboys
first and foremost I love the guys that
I join the game with these guys are I
made bonds and you know when you go to
war and you're gang banging and similar
to I compared to going to war
it's a different War than our U.S
military faces and and nothing but
respect to them but we fight like a an
urban War amongst other gang members in
the similar system of war and we're not
really ever contrary to popular belief I
want to say this gang members are not
out there attacking innocent civilians
we don't go out and shoot innocent
people for initiation that's a myth that
America has placed on gangs street gang
members are not going to lose a member
to the jail system because I need to
shoot Stephanie for initiation on the
street corner that's that's a myth every
now and then that happens accidentally
and it bothers us just as much as it
bothers the society we live in gang
members aren't just targeting people for
murder I mean there are robberies and
stuff but initially we don't really
focus on innocent people we like to
fight people that are playing the same
game as we are in a Monopoly board game
system
if that makes any sense and um
uh
what was the question again
transitioning I was asking if getting
involved in gangs and all that kind of
stuff got in the way of doing something
else good okay so yes because graffiti
was my calling man I love graffiti I can
close my eyes and still smell spray
paint on the 405 freeway at midnight I
remember I remember the just the sound
of shaking a Krylon spray paint can
because before graffiti now these kids
are lucky these amazing graffiti artists
that you see this graffiti all over LA
and The Valley to San Diego to Oxnard
and Ventura these kids are so good at it
because they don't have the parameters
that we did Growing Up growing up in the
90s and late 80s we had to we were
limited to two types of spray paint
Rust-Oleum or Krylon we had to steal all
of this we had to make our own spray can
tips to either be skinnier or fatter
spring we had to steal markers in
abundance there wasn't an abundance of
all these supplies today those graffiti
stores made for these kids and mind you
I want to say this these kids are not
being attacked by local business owners
would shoot and attack us back in the
90s they would have us arrested we were
being chased and hunted by cops because
graffiti was such a horrible thing back
then and we're also being attacked by
gang members as we travel the streets in
the middle of the night trying to get
through these projects and up and down
on freeways through apartment complexes
and it's it's it's really easy for kids
to Graffiti today there's a difference
in a graffiti artist and a a I guess a
graffiti just a street bomber tagger I
was a street bomber and I mean we had I
could like I can the sound of a spray
can shaking is something that just
brings happiness to my ears the smell of
spray paint at midnight when you're
hanging over the 405 freeway by the
Ventura by right by the Burbank Crossing
I remember so many nights we would just
I would pack my backpack full of spray
paint Mark and start on governor and
Woodman and Mission Hills we'd take the
last 158 bus that would take us to
Ventura and Cahuenga the kawanga pass by
Universal Studios we'd get off the bus
mind you it's midnight now 1205. no more
buses run the only way we're getting
back to Mission Hills Arleta is uh we're
walking and we all got backpacks full of
spray paint and we would just destroy
the city on our way back and every
morning at about 5 a.m when that sun's
coming up over the spreading grounds on
the corner of Devonshire and Woodman
where it turns into Arleta I remember
just taking that long couple couple
block walk back home sneaking in my
window graffiti was just something I
should have stuck more to because it
could have turned into an art career a
lot of the guys that I did that with are
now famous artists they're getting paid
lots of money for with these galleries
downtown graffiti is so common people
around the world are buying these
canvases for 20 30 000. my friend big
sleepy alone has turned gang graffiti
into an amazing career how do you feel
about tagging some innocent person's
business who's just trying to struggle
to make it make a killing make it I mean
I didn't think about it back then today
you think about it but then again today
these these business owners you're
talking about are actually reaching out
and saying hey would you do some artwork
on our wall so it's like I said the
times have changed back then we didn't
think about it to us it was just about
getting famous and getting our name up
and in all honesty we weren't really
hurting nobody a little pain you might
it might have cost you some money to
paint but we didn't physically attack
you we weren't
taking over the sidewalk in front of
your job with [__] drugs and like
filth I mean it was just graffiti
yeah now mankind is is destructive
aren't we I have this conversation with
my girlfriend all the time I feel like
man is is man is very destructive we're
such a weird destructive uh species for
sure War has been in our history for
it's all we know how to do destroy and
Conquer divide move to the next location
do the same thing all over again yeah
yeah and all these young boys you're how
old when you start oh God I'm probably
12 11 maybe 12 when I first started
graffiti what is it the testosterone
kicks in and you just want to uh
fighting conquer and beat somebody up I
guess but for me starting all that was
just about me getting famous getting out
of my little small town of Mission Hills
in Sun Valley and just getting famous
from here to LA
yeah
and how have you changed over the years
how old are you now I'm 45 I'm about to
be 46 in April yeah you've Melody oh
totally I'm totally mellow I'm not if
you would have met me I I say this a lot
if you would have met me I've been sober
for coming up on five years in May if
you would have met me even my first year
in sobriety I was an [__] I didn't
know how to be a good man I didn't know
how to have a successful relationship I
couldn't handle being disrespected at a
store and learning how to walk away
I mean I paroled from prison in 2013
with that attitude where anything was
it's on site somebody gives you an
attitude on the street yeah I had to I
had to like I said before I had to
unlearn a lot of that behavior that was
taught in prison what would you
typically do in that situation I
probably would have punched somebody if
you disrespect me or bumped into me in
line didn't say excuse me stepped on my
shoe we're rude to my girlfriend got in
the way of our kids somehow I would have
flighted you but today I have to learn
it that this doesn't work out here it
doesn't work out here you know if
everybody acted like that we'd be in a
worse shape than we are now does the
prison system
rehabilitate at all
ah
I want to say that it's there if you
want it how many years did you spend I
did 19 years three three different
Collective uh terms 19 years total it's
a lot I want to say also the prison
system I think if you want it because my
my friend again lonely went through some
exhausting rehabilitative counseling and
therapy to change his life and to re
reprogram his brain
but they don't necessarily just give
that to people you have to go after that
in prison there's a lot of bad stuff in
prison like I say but there's also like
a lot of good stuff I learned in prison
there's a lot of good things you can
take from prison especially when it
comes to working with people and
learning how to be respectful follow
rules uh get involved in a group and
contribute to a group a lot of these
things can uh they can facilitate your
transfer into the world
but then again you also have to be smart
enough and adult enough to realize I got
to leave this stuff here because these
ways don't come but this stuff I can
definitely transition with you know
have you had any contact with your son
since that video I left him okay so I
left him a message
um he read the message he didn't respond
I sent him a screenshot because I don't
have his phone number we only
communicate on Instagram I sent him a
screenshot of the interview and I sent
him a quick message I said listen a lot
of the stuff I wanted to tell you is in
this video
on YouTube I I don't get a chance to
tell you but if you listen to this I'm
not making fun of the fact that I said
you get me for clothes because I'd still
give them to you but I want you to watch
what I say because this is what I've
been trying to tell you I just want you
to hear me tell you why I left and it's
in this interview he read the interview
I mean he he hearted it he read the
comment and then he said I want to get
some time I'm going to go watch this for
you and that's where it ended nothing
nothing since forgiveness is the answer
to everything
yeah if he can't if he can understanding
is the key to forgiveness so that's why
I do these videos I mean he doesn't have
to forgive me but if he can understand
at least why I did what I did that's a
huge thing
that's that's that's good enough for me
that's great yeah
where's your life go from here
I I don't know I'm really getting I'm
really having fun with I'm overwhelmed
but having fun with helping people I I
mean I've been man since our interview
Mark I I've I've talked to so many
people that are from here to Australia
that are just like me really you'd be
surprised how many people in all these
other countries do not only was there
graffiti gangs drugs and my common
answer is well we're all the same once
you do drugs you don't matter whether
you're in Nova Scotia Canada uh
Melbourne Australia we're all the same
as addicts we all have the same behavior
as well the same disease we have the
same selfish self-centered thinking and
it's nice to be able to talk to so many
people that have families and have also
reached changed their [__] and are nice
enough and take their time to reach out
to me
as your self-destructive Tendencies kind
of faded away a bit yeah I used to sell
sabotage a lot I don't do that anymore
totally self-destructive yeah I don't do
that anymore at all or the face would
you would you consider your face tattoos
as part of the self-destructive Behavior
I talked about this the other day I feel
like I mean part of me sometimes wishes
I didn't have it and my mom bought me
this Kat Von D tattoo makeup for people
with tattoos to cover their face and I
did it with one of my friends Adam Adam
uh covered all your tattoos I covered my
whole head and when I looked at myself
in the mirror Mark I was lost I was
freaked out I didn't like it and I had
to go through the realization that this
is me and it just like I said before if
I were to change all of this that I've
been through I couldn't do what I'm
doing now and help people and maybe who
I am these tattoos they're just a part
of me and I think it actually helps me
bridge the gap between a lot of people
out there on the street and the normal
so to speak nine to five construction
guy or nine to five lawyer or the guy
that works behind a desk at Microsoft I
can touch people even if you're in
recovery that Joe at Microsoft camp I
can help this community out here that
other people can't with these tattoos so
no I'm okay with it you have tattoos all
over your body oh down to my toes
private areas everything really yes yes
you've had some removed oh my God I had
my penis lasered uh I've had my face
lasered twice I've had my chest laser
the insides of my arms lasered what kind
of things are you removing I had a bunch
of just dumb hateful stuff from prison
that had to go one of those things I was
talking about that just doesn't transfer
out here into the world
a bunch of stuff like that yeah
those those tattoos came from prison
yeah
there's moments and memories you make
with people in prison that are up here I
got them up here I don't need some
stupid thing to remind me of it I can't
ever forget some of the [__] I've been
through I I can't close my eyes some
nights and not see things or remember
things and some of the times like I was
telling uh I was telling someone the
other day that these memories jump out
at me at the oddest times
like my brain has repressed a lot of
this I think for safety of myself and
some of these memories come back and uh
yeah just a lot of that stuff had to go
what's what's the most uh
horrific thing that you've been through
either well the story I told last time
was pretty bad about watching that kid
dramatically get
um
there's a couple things I I could uh I
have a recruitment story from prison I
could uh or there's also like uh I was
uh set to go in the army right out of
high school before I joined the Navy I
was supposed to go in the army with one
of my friends I had met doing community
service his name was Ryan rest in peace
and this weighs heavy on my conscience
because I was
I'm sort of to blame for this um me and
my friend Ryan became friends doing
community labor for some we had both
been arrested for some similar different
crimes we were doing community labor I
was living in the valley he was living
in Santa Clarita and we were doing
Caltrans work we had to drive up to New
Hall in the morning go do freeway pick
up trash pick up stuff like that
Caltrans on the side of the road yeah
side of the road stuff we see on the
freeway whether you're wearing a yellow
orgs vest for safety um
on our last night of couches we had both
discovered also we're both enlisted to
the Army lo and behold we're both
supposed to ship out the same day so we
decided on our last night or night
before that two nights before we decided
hey it's Friday let's go party let's go
and mind you in the process I realize
I'm from one gang in Sun Valley I
realize he's from a neighboring gang to
us in Sun Valley which is this gang is
full force 20 times more active more
stronger more involved than my gang was
he and we had the idea let's go to both
of our hoods let's go get high and party
and I brought my girlfriend along who's
mind you well I was actively gang
banging my high school sweetheart was a
17 year old girl that's half Sri Lankan
half white she's and she is not like she
just looks at this like it's cool has no
understanding of this lifestyle and we
decide my dad lets me borrow his old
Chevy Corsica 1991 primered little
beater and we go out and party him and
um
in the process we realize well we're
both from Big gangs that were active in
the 90s and we decided to go smoke crack
which is obviously never a great idea I
don't recommend that we're smoking crack
so our paranoids increased a little bit
my high school girlfriend is driving the
car because I can't really drive when
I'm loaded I got I don't have this is my
first time rolling around the valley
without a gun
and he's in the back seat I'm in the
front passenger my high school
girlfriend was driving the vehicle seat
belts on he wouldn't wear one I remember
specifically one of the details that
hurts me is I remember saying bro put
your seatbelt on we're driving around
someone crack he wouldn't do it
we go to My Hood we party in my hood I
introduce him to all my friends
everyone's cool with him we go to his
hood next and he's shocked and he's
scared and he's like [__] I've never
been here I'm like wait a minute what do
you mean you've never been here
he goes well I I've never been here I
got jumped in out in Santa Cruz I've
never been
To My Hood and I'm like imagine for a
second
you're jumped into the most strong
active gang the San Fernando Valley has
ever produced
you live in Santa Clarita you got jumped
in in Santa Clarita by a couple kids
that had moved out there after
previously having a foundation here and
understanding this gang you get jumped
in out there and never have been out
here and I take you to what is like
[__] going excuse me going to Vietnam
he's scared none of the dudes know him
they all know me because of our gangs
are uh like rival not Rivals but we get
along and we're interacting with each
other I'm shaking hands and you know Pat
and backs what's up beers fast uh all
this [__] I score some drugs for us and
they're like who the [__] are you homie
you know and then now he's looked at as
like who the [__] are you down here and
and he's like well I'm trusting you I'm
trusting you from this gang and they're
like well we don't know you homie
we leave he's so uncomfortable that I
finally I agree I'd say I say bye to my
friends that are from that gang so mind
you picture this I'm more welcome in
that dude's gang than he was
we leave we're in the car and he's and I
finally I turn around what the [__] bro
how do you not tell me like how could
you have never been to your hood and
he's like well I don't know I just got
jumped I'm like bro this this isn't a
game dog
and mind you this is I could almost cry
because this gets real serious as the
night progresses on
this kid is like scary man well I didn't
know I mean and I'm and I'm late I'm
ripping into this kid what the [__] do
you mean you don't know dog how are you
gonna be from a gang you've never been
there you don't understand the ways of
the streets and and I'm like I'm shocked
I feel bad I'm embarrassed mind you my
reputation is still intact and we keep
smoking crack
now this the last conversation we had
was that where I was a dick to this kid
I was a dick I was I was hard on him and
I was I I talked down to him and and um
we drive by Kennedy High School which is
farther into the north central part of
the San Fernando Valley Granada Hills
area there was a football game and uh my
gang had been going to war with
this tagging crew mind you at this time
in the valley in the 90s all these
tagging Crews like I said before had
clicked up with gangs so all these Titan
Crews that like I was had already been
become small clicks of bigger gangs in
the valley
we had beef with this one tagging crew
that was pretty prominent they had all
split off also sideways into all these
other gangs
so it's kind of a cluster [__]
we're driving by and a car load pulls
out that I recognize as an enemy from
this high school football game on a
Friday night they get behind us
immediately
inside this vehicle are
three members of a tagging crew these
three members of this tank who are also
from one of them is just the tagger to
the driver is from my friend's gang the
driver is from the same gang that my
friend is from and that tagging crew
he doesn't know that his homeboy is in
my car
his passenger seat driver is from a very
big prominent La neighborhood a huge
bigger neighborhood than all of us those
are the guys that are actively involved
in this they proceed to chase us through
the valley
my girlfriend is terrified mind he's
some little Catholic school girl from
Notre Dame has no concept on how to
aggressively drive a small compact Chevy
Corsica through the streets of the
valley
speeding around quarter boom we finally
make it to the side street in front of
CSUN Cal State Northridge High School
make a left the car proceeds to get
behind us
they hit their lights their lights went
black I knew what time it was because
I've been actively I'm active in the
gang life let's move the lights went off
I said get the [__] down on the floor
he doesn't listen my girlfriend even
goes okay she gets down
these guys start opening up I mean I say
it sounded like a Vietnam shooting but
that's what my thinking tells me but I
know all I know is there was two
Shooters in that vehicle they were
shooting at us through one of them was
through the the
Senator sunroof one of them was out the
front right passenger side they were
very big caliber guns I don't remember I
remember hearing the initial fuse a lot
of bullets hitting my car boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom
my friend looks up out the back when I
all I said was don't [__] look as
soon as he looked the first like the
third or fourth maybe the first couple
bullets hitting one hit him in the head
his head popped and I mean when I say
popped at me we were all blanketed with
teeth brain matter it was just
disgusting again like I said before
unless you've seen something like this
you have no concept of how gruesome and
hard something like this is
it's everywhere
now the bullets are coming they're
they're really firing at us now at this
point and I'm I'm trying to get down
under the front under the front uh the
dashboard my girlfriend is at that point
is down crouched down the seat belt so
tight in her that she's screaming
because she's trying to just get around
this corner on a dark Street they pull
up next to us unload some more I watched
it's weird this is how I say god Odin
someone was on my back someone had my
six because the bullets three or four of
them went through the top part of my
jeans right here bang bang bang
didn't hit me
my my flannel is completely soaking
blood there's sticky pieces of cherry
pie looking brain matter all over those
teeth in my girlfriend's hair there's
teeth on the windshield they finally
keep shooting and speed off but in the
process of this last drive-by they shot
out the the tires car does one of those
Flip Flip Flip and [__] Talladega
Nights type [__] hits the Park Grand
Cherokee and they speed off
I'm pretty sure I was knocked out the
kite the guys hit a right Turner a right
corner fast I remember hearing Sirens
real quick they got caught because they
were speeding around a corner where a
motorcycle cop happened to be amazingly
enough and it's funny because a lot of
people will will comment on what
happened but they'll forget the fact
that these these dudes
kept speeding and and from what I
understand from what I remember hearing
is the the cops caught up you ever hear
the term Smoking Gun well that's the
exact example of getting caught with a
literally Smoking Gun and a car full of
shell casings the call goes out cops
arrive real soon I pull myself out of an
upside down car I pulled my girlfriend
out of the car her ribs are broken her
nose is broken to the side of her face
she's screaming I get her to the
shoulder
I go back to the car and my homeboy is
stuck in the [__] through the week
half in the windshield half out he has
no head it's disgusting there's [__]
everywhere I'm covered in blood cops
arrive and they arrest me they they
assumed with that type of violence that
I was a shooter too I was in a [__]
holding tank all weekend my mom had to
go kick up a storm at the Devonshire
division because I was a minor
uh
and the last thing I have to say about
is I I argued with my friend because he
wasn't cool or he wasn't down he hadn't
he wasn't as tough as I was because he
hadn't been to his hood and the [__]
I'm left with we were supposed to leave
to the Army on a Monday it's Friday and
I took this kid out to party and he's
dead
I got to tell this kid's mom he's dead
and I took him out to party in Sun
Valley
and
I was more worried at that time that
how how embarrassing how [__] up it
was you've never been to your hood man
[__] your [__] the hood this kid died
because I took him out on a journey
thinking I was cool trying to show off
in the East San Fernando Valley
and this kid didn't get to go to the
Army didn't get to see his mom didn't
get to say goodbye to his mom and his
mom I feel bad because she kept trying
to wanted to want to sit down privately
with me and I was just so embarrassed I
couldn't talk to her I didn't want to
tell her all she wanted to hear was last
moments of her son and
and I was just I was just so embarrassed
I mean and then I have I still have at
my mom's house we have that flannel in a
Ziploc baggie I kept it for a memory I I
uh I never could let go of it
because that
whatever was left with that kid is on
that flannel and it's um
it's horrible it's sad and and uh it
just shows how serious gangs are and
when kids talk about it like it's fun
and when kids talk about like on
Instagram acting all cool and
like that [__] is serious
and my friend died because of it and he
died because he didn't know he didn't
listen he didn't have the skill set I
would say to navigate active Gang
Lifestyle not that that's important
but it somewhat is because you have to
know how to react in those situations
and eventually eventually I ended up the
the Nate she made his mother made such a
stink that
the Army canceled my contract and I had
to figure out a way to get back in the
service because that was my goal to get
in the service and I ended up getting in
the Navy Navy didn't care about none of
that they
drafted me I mean they enlisted me and I
went out went out to boot camp and [__]
but
lost my career in the army was
embarrassed
but I didn't really realize that until I
I had to do a lot a lot of time a long
time later for a long time I didn't
really process it many nights in prison
I would sit there and think about it as
kids did I remember going to his funeral
and I remember just people there crying
and there was no and this is what's
crazy too because it sticks out in my
head this is how this is how insane that
lifestyle is when I showed up at his
funeral I was decked out with my hood my
neighborhood gang stuff
and I show up there by myself
there's no other gang members there and
my only thought I remember the only
thing I was thinking about is why are
these homies here this kid died
and the worst part of the story is the
driver of that car was from his gang the
driver of that car was one of the ones
that killed his own homeboy and because
of all these little other inner turmoil
beefs with tagging foods and LA gangs
and areas he killed his own homeboy and
he didn't even find out about it until
he was on trial he had to sit there and
live with the fact that he killed his
own homeboy not knowing shooting into a
car not knowing who was in the vehicle
it's and I and I kept remembering the
funeral and all I kept taking from the
funeral was Jam none of his even homies
are here I think there might have been
one
but nobody like none of his homeboys
he's from a gang and died in this
lifestyle and none of his friends even
came
I came his mom came my mom came
all these normal Santa Clarita kids
showed up to this kid's funeral
and none of his homeboys from his gang
showed up do you feel like you're like
somebody's watching over you
the fact that you've never been I would
like to say that because something was
man I mean three bullet holes from what
I think that some of the bullets they
found were a 45 hollow point shell
casings that's an amazing weapon and the
rest was like a 380 or a 32 Beretta from
the shell casings they said recovering
the vehicle but mine were huge holes so
they had to be the 45 I mean to think
that that many times missed me and that
and that span of spinning in a vehicle
someone's watching out for me bro
someone what do you think the solution
is to all this gang violence I don't
think there is a solution to gangs I I
think the gangs are gangs are
generational gangs are
there are it's a legacy in history we
have in Los Angeles it's something that
I don't think won't stop they'll take
breaks like if you've noticed the past
10 to 15 years they've been kind of
dormant well lately I said last time
they're they're they're starting to come
back full circle now we're back on the
blocks now we're the dress code's
revolving back to what it was Trends
change they leave and they come back
and they're starting to roll back from
what I've seen driving around L.A
because I'm around and through La all
the time and I have probably doing my
prison time I got home Boys in almost
every Hood from here to San Francisco
one at least one I could say probably
from almost every neighborhood gang [__]
blood Asian essays whites skinheads all
of them and I'm telling you they're
coming back and I think there really
isn't no solution because there's a lot
of history with these gangs a lot of
these gangs began as football teams car
clubs dance clubs break dancing Crews uh
backyard party DJ Cruise there's
generations of history and a legacy that
these gangs leave in these areas
and it goes back to what I said we don't
necessarily kill innocent people it's
usually accidental when that happens
you know and and I just I don't think
there is a solution to it kids could be
taught and we could talk to kids
but you can't really change a kid's mind
a kid is going to do what he's going to
do
I like to say that if I have a chance I
want to talk to him and just tell them I
can tell you what's going to happen
I'd like to give you the the series of
of
steps that's going to happen should you
choose this because I know damn well
where that road leads I've been down
that road so just let me give you the
facts so you're prepared with a tool
chest of knowledge when you take this
road because if you took this one it's
easier
but you're probably going to go here so
let me hold on homeboy let me give you a
tool chest of what you can take with you
down that road because it's about to get
you're about to go through some storms
what's the basic message that you you
want to share with the young kids
like I said last time maybe follow your
heart
follow your heart and think about your
family
and think and think about prison I know
it looks kind of cool sometimes when
you're young and you want to you want to
have that that uh what's it called you
want to have that Legacy or that that uh
remembrance on your back that that honor
that badge of honor I went to the Joint
I was with all my homeboys I made a name
for myself it is cool but sometimes
people don't come home from prison and
prison is an extremely lonely place as
your family members die off your
girlfriends leave because let me tell
you something brother your girlfriends
will leave baby mamas will leave people
will not sit around for years while you
sit in prison act a tough guy and catch
case after case after case because to
stay active that's what that means for
all these kids that want to be that guy
that that mobster that
not see that whatever it is for your
crew
it's cool
but those people usually don't make it
home
there's a good movie I can reference
it's called shot caller if all of you
out there haven't seen the movie shot
caller I recommend you go watch it
because that is not only a true story
but that's usually what happens there
usually isn't ways out if you choose to
stay that path
and what do you you're raising your
girlfriend's kids yeah I have a step
kids with my girlfriend they're awesome
yeah you're you're getting your chances
being a dad now I know it's like god
Odin gave me a second chance because I I
missed it and they know I feel like the
energy of the universe knows that I I at
that moment I chose the best thing I
thought for him
and now that I've changed I get a second
chance
you know I was also saying too it's
funny because knock on wood but uh
my energy is different today people are
always like well don't you get pulled
over in that big old flat sheet flashy
Lincoln on those 22s and Loud stereo and
the way you look don't you get pulled
over all the time it's funny because I
usually don't get bothered that much
anymore my energy is different it's
weird when you're living different I
could look like this but my energy is
different so the cops aren't that I mean
unless I'm texting and driving swerving
which has happened
um the cops really don't [__] with me
anymore they really don't they do their
thing and I do mine
and you stay out of trouble yeah I mean
I'm not I'm not committing crime you
pretty much have to physically touch me
my mom my girlfriend her kids one of my
close friends for me to get involved
like that there's I mean I'm not
plotting on nobody I'm not I'm not
robbing you I think once there was uh
recently I think I I didn't scan a third
item at Walmart that's that's the extent
of my crime right now
all right Matt thank you so much for
coming back you're welcome thank you for
having me you're always interesting to
talk to you thank you thanks man all
right